This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well, no. Well go to your mom's house.
Christina Jean.
Yes. Working in the people. See you
May 31st and the belly room comedy
stores sold out. Sold out. That's it.
That's how I'm running my Netflix
set right before I go tape it.
June 4th and what's Las Vegas for us?
Oh yeah. What's Las Vegas Moms? Moms,
penis.
Mom's bedroom.
Heard it referred to like that
Mom's Vegas. A taping for that.
For the Netflix special.
The degenerates.
If you want to come see that taping
for free, go to Christina p online.
Use the Promo Code your mom and
you'll get preferential seating.
Just give him a few days to get back to
you. It takes a while. It's free seats,
but uh, the only way you'll get great
seating is if you put in the code.
Your mom and Joey Diaz was on that lineup.
They just added Brad Williams and Jay
Oakerson and I can't know the other two
checks the girls are on there. I don't
know them cause we're east coasters,
but it's going to be amaze,
amaze.
November 24th in man, Diego, California
at House of Blues and then December 8th,
Jude Dork titties at
the Grammercy theater.
Only a handful of tickets left on that
one. Tickets at Christina p online.
Go for it Tom.
It's your turn.
Oh, so I was just verifying
this and it is true if you, uh,
if you are living in the Braya area,
uh,
those shows have been sold out for
a while. But what happened is, uh,
the club is moving down the street still.
Embrya it's still on the same block,
but they're moving to a much bigger space.
So they have opened up tickets to
every show because of the new capacity.
So they'll probably go pretty quick. Uh,
the ones that were on sale went fast.
But, uh, if you missed out
on the original tickets,
you can go to Thomson [inaudible]
dot com slash tour and get the,
um,
tickets to those shows.
I believe it's August 2nd and
third at the brand improv. Um,
Saturdays almost gone at the west
palm breast balls, beach real pros.
And West Palm,
Florida at the Improv there.
Those are on sale. And uh, let's see,
I have um, some shows and
tickets left in, fill her up.
Delphia um,
I have shows a,
the second show still available in,
what's it called?
What's your tits called? Uh, uh, know. Um,
so yeah. Here's the, uh, the new
exciting show. Eugene, Oregon is on sale.
Let's Eugene. Yeah. Two genes.
Oh, jeans. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The on sale is Friday.
The presale will be this Wednesday.
Uh,
May 30th, beginning at 10:00 AM
Pacific. The Mcdonald's theater,
the password if you'd like to get tickets
during the presale is champ. C H a.
N T. Ridiculous. I don't know
why they give that one. Yeah,
Tibia.
That show is going to be October
4th at the Mcdonald Theater. Uh,
there's also some other shows
on sale ball, Sacramento,
Fresno,
a couple of hours.
Go to time square.com/tour and uh,
uh, yeah. Enjoy that. Please
get tickets to see us. We're
very excited about it. Gene,
you're ready to get down to business.
I'm so excited for today's episode.
It's going to be a fun one. Gene.
It's been a long time in the making.
You prepped for this for a long
time. We got a lot going on. Yeah.
You ready to do it?
Yeah, let's get started.
Oh, he's birds. Birds.
Hey people
up a storm out here.
Really look at that shit. Shit. NATO
don't bring anyone loving.
Well Go.
Go to your mom's house.
You
know what I'm saying? Yeah. Uh,
that was just a little thing to
get the show started, you know?
Right in our wheel house. A lot of shit.
You know what I'm saying? Excited voice.
But um, yeah, today's going to be fun.
We had a lot to get into. First of all,
can we get into the your jacket?
Yeah. What's up? First of all,
are you Ukrainian? Are you Sullivanian?
Are You Hungarian? Like what?
What's the look you're going for is all
that Slavic? I'm a dope producer. Yo.
You know what I'm saying? This is so my
tribe right now, I'm really feeling it.
Maybe, I don't know. I feel
like it's just, you know,
up folk came through through
me up motherfucking dope
jacket and I've put it on
what's the flag of what a former
rush Soviet countries that,
I don't know what that is.
Which satellite country.
I think I saw a Dominican guy wearing
it. I was like, where'd you get that?
It's pretty dove though. Yeah, I like it.
I mean it's definitely loud and makes a
lot of statements. No word on a plane.
People we're definitely
noticing. Yeah. Jesus guy.
If you wore that to Hungary and Matt,
like my relatives and friends,
they'd be like that. That's a good jacket.
This is nice. This is good stuff here.
No good. Jagat you leave that behind.
Maybe you're like house music.
Absolutely. Like house music to, uh,
I remember when I worked with
a German and she was like,
how come nobody likes house music?
And I was like, I don't know.
It's not 1994 talking about we're
Americans. And then she was like,
once it was dancing, this
playground, house music, good luck.
Take that foreign shit out man.
When I was in Madrid for a semester,
every,
every club like the UK,
uh,
Hungary to booming everywhere.
The UK, they love that Shit.
It,
it was good. I know that never
really took off here though.
Something about that sensibility
is not, I dunno, it's not,
it's not as like they're,
it feels ma that's mainstream.
That's what people are into.
If you're young, if you're
cool, that's what you like.
And here it wasn't like that. Now it's
too, I don't know. But then again,
we liked that club music.
People like, you know,
people would do drugs and they
raves and stuff like that was cool,
but I don't know how I'm at attach. What
do I know? I know. I don't know anything.
We're, um, we're, we're basically
lost on our television shows.
You know what's so funny is that as
we're sitting here recording now,
all I can think about,
it's like when can we go back upstairs
and put the TV on and finish where we
left off? I know there's so many good
shows we're into right now. Well,
here's what happens is we dry up,
the well dries up and
then I find the TLC APP.
What happens is the well dries up on
really amazing award winning television.
Other words,
scripted mega shows that are phenomenal,
like coming to an end on the Americans
set that were kind of talking on the
marriage. He never got into the
Americans. You want to deep dive,
you'll have six seasons. So good. Uh,
we're watching Handmaid's tale tale
is really picking up a thank God.
There's finally hope. I was about to
commit suicide a couple episodes back.
So now we're, we're having some help and
I'm stoked. We're really, really fired up.
It's, it's good. It's, I mean,
this, this last ending was
just like Bam. I love that.
I kind of reminds me of when one of
those shows where you go, well, all,
I don't want to give it away,
but it's like when you're
watching one of the amazing,
like a breaking bad and something
central that you're used to changes,
all of a sudden you're like, I going
to go from here. I Know Sopranos,
like a character's just out of
the picture. You're like, what?
What's going to happen now? They
just really fucked shit up. Um,
I'm super excited for hand
jobs help. But anyways, we get,
we run through these shows and so then
you're great at finding the filler shows,
the um, the outliers,
the marginalized shows.
We'll tip our hat and
just tell the network Tlc,
you have really outdone yourself.
If you have an apple TV,
I recommend just going and getting the
TLC APP and just scrolling their reality
reality lineup. There's like,
it's a joke. It's a fucking joke,
but it's so good that dwarves,
it's called big and little big and little.
That's about fat dwarves dwarves,
which I heard I fell asleep. But you
said it wasn't as funny as we know.
It was way, way more depressing
than I thought it would be. See,
that's the problem with Tlc is they
get you, they get the empathy. Yeah.
Like I don't want to be empathetic.
I want to laugh.
I want to enjoy my fat dwarves,
you know,
and then you got me feeling for them like
Oh my God dammit. And then there was a,
yeah there's, they have a whole
bunch of fat stuff like that.
I lost all the fat and
now my skin hangs off me.
It's called like skin tight on that one.
And that was depressing too.
It's also hard to watch.
And then there's a
satin alive fat and Catlin
that family and yeah,
just all kinds of fat shit. Yeah. And
then they have a lot of gender stuff,
you know, I don't watch that cause
I feel bad it's a little kid.
But then there's one now that we are
really deep into called lost in transition
and I know it is so
captivating. The premises,
there are married couples that
had been married for a while.
I mean we're talking anywhere from
like eight to sometimes 30 years.
Multiple children, established
relationships, children for most.
And in each of these marriages the
man has told the woman did he wants to
transition to a woman.
And I mean you are really,
it is like jumping into a household
and seeing the biggest bomb drop in a
relationship.
You're,
you're literally getting to peek in to
a private life and seeing somebody go,
I am going to blow up what we have been
used to for three decades and thing is
the interesting part is that the trans
part isn't that interesting to me anymore
because I feel like we've seen
so many shows and we're kind of,
we have a better understanding of that.
The reactions,
the way people handle it.
It's the emotional drama.
That's calculus and
there's this one couple,
they've been married 24 years.
They have three children or four,
which, which won the Ohio
woman who's like just the most,
they have to come off
her whole dream in life.
The one that's married to my dad
basically. Yeah. The husband is like,
he's got a belly, he's got the
traditional bald, like horseshoe.
He just looks like one of
my dad's golfing friends.
Never going to be a good looking
woman. It's that guy, probably not.
And he's just like,
ah.
And he's so happy that it's that
he's told her back it up. No,
the bagging of the best
part is that she is like,
I mean,
all I ever wanted in life was to get
married and have children and have a house
and go to the hobby lobby on Saturday.
Like her, she's very simple. Yeah.
All she wanted out of life was the house,
the husband,
like the lionfish paddling and
she did the life that she wanted.
She's living the life that she wanted,
but he drops it on her one night.
She's like, and then, and then you see,
you see real, I mean, devastation
that, not that he's doing it.
It's that life is now not,
it's changing.
And so then they're like, what
are they going to do? Like what?
We're going to get divorced
and get separate places.
He is like flipping pancakes.
And he's like, we sure are.
And he's like cleaning up, cleaning
up shit in the garage. And he's like,
I cannot fucking wait for you.
And they're sitting there in this
interview and, uh, he's like,
he's like, you know, it was so hard
to tell her. He's like, but you know,
here I was my whole life,
you know,
my wedding day and the birth of our
children and I was just so devastated and
miserable guess cause he knew that he
was trans from day from why they got
married and he just couldn't come out
and he couldn't say anything and he was
like, I was so devastated.
And I'm like, Oh God, I'm so
miserable. And she was like,
that's so hurtful to hear
dates.
What? Like she's clearly
like, wait a minute. Those
are the best days of my life.
The birth of our children are, oh
no, no, not mine. It's not mine.
The best part is that,
like you said, he's one,
he's flipping the pancakes and she's like,
I've never been on my own before.
And he's like, Yep, it's going to
be tight. Not a lot of money. Yeah.
I don't even know how to balance my
checkbook a separate place. So he's like,
the budget really going to be tight
so you're not the not splurge anyway.
I'm going to go out
so great.
He doesn't give a fuck.
I think he's so relieved to come out.
I mean you could tell the
way it is off of off of them.
And then there's this other woman who's
this really educated like engineer and
she's in her fifties and um,
and she doesn't understand.
She doesn't get it at all. He's
just gay and it's a choice. No,
she thinks he's like, I want
to go to Cabo. You can't,
we can't do it. She's like, do
you understand if you do this,
it'll fuck shit up between us. And he's
like, yeah, do you understand that?
She's like, you're so selfish. No,
really doesn't comprehend that.
It's like a brain thing and he really
does need to do this to feel whole.
He doesn't, she doesn't get it. No,
but actually that's kind
of fascinating to watch,
to be back to it because you know that
everybody, not everybody, but that,
that generation probably empathizes like
shares her set point of view that it's
kind of voluntary maybe.
Well it's generational.
Probably be like, yeah, these guys
choosing to be a warmer, come on by the,
or now you're choosing it.
They just don't have like the
same empathy and understanding.
So to watch her spiral has
just been fantastic too. Um,
and then her friend comes over who is
like the know it all and who's intervening
in their marriage and you're like, bitch,
why are you, are you meeting or anything?
And she's like, I am not
a lesbian. I don't like,
I'm not gay.
Cause then she's really out of it.
I'll be living with a woman then
and I don't like women like that.
She keeps saying that over. She likes
penises and this isn't the house.
It's so great. What a
great show. Great show.
Kind of wonder what,
what, what would you do?
Fucking I would, I would have to
be committed like I love, but I,
you know, cause I really do
think about this seriously.
Not We watching like I love you so much
that I would stand by you clearly and
I'd be like,
okay,
well we'll transition you and you
can live with us and braise our kids.
But like I may have to have a boyfriend,
I may have to step out.
Well we can't do it anymore.
You're not a man, you'll,
you're gonna transition and
you're probably not going
to be very attractive as a
woman. Let's face it.
It's also very hurtful.
You're going to be the ugliest woman that
dial it back a little. No, I'm serious.
You're not meant to be a woman.
Like your shoulders are too broad.
You have so much hair.
Could you imagine,
although the hormones will make
the hair fall out, I think,
I think that that'd be a pretty cute,
you'd be horrendous as a woman.
What would you do if I was like,
I'm a man. Oh, I'd be so into it.
That would be, it would be, I think I,
I love you like that to where I'd be like,
we have that spare room and that
can be yours. And uh, you know,
if you start lifting,
we can start sharing clothes
and then you can get your second
Dalmatian wife like you want. Oh my God.
Can you imagine her and you and me
living together how the fuck would be,
can I say something?
I kind of would just to,
for the sake of the family and be like,
I'll just raise our kids.
And what would have the kids call
Dalmatian though? Just by her first name.
Just what are they going to call me?
They'll be like, Daddy, daddy and Daddy.
Yeah. Daddy, Daddy, Daddy,
daddy and Jenny now that,
so he's a boy is so you, me,
misty. She wouldn't be named Jenny.
Boring.
Yeah.
Misty Crystal Shandy.
Be Mommy to him for a while and he'd be,
it'd be hard to break it for him.
He's so young. Or maybe he
would start calling. We did.
We just have him call you your new name.
What would be your dude name?
Um, that's tough. It's so hard to
choose. I choose like a regular name when
that, when the one woman, the,
the lady who's not ready for it,
who's older and goes,
so do you have a name?
Like a woman's name that
you've always wanted so much
contempt. He was like, yeah.
She was like, what is it? He was
like, Lucy from, I love Lucy.
I love that show. And she goes, I fucking
hate that name. It's a stupid name.
Suzanne.
Cool about
it. And then there's other, they've
been together for 14 years now.
They're the ones that for kids.
Yeah.
And they live in a cul de sac where
everybody knows everyone's business and
she's really trying to hold it together
with him, even though he's transitioning.
And you can tell she's just eating those
feelings. Like she's getting fatter,
fatter every year.
I have a special treat for you that I
want to get all before I guess arrives.
Sure. So for people who
may have missed last week,
so a Christina is taping another
Netflix special called the degenerates.
Yes. Uh, Joey Diaz is doing
it, at least a Trager trigger.
And that's her name. Yes. Jay
Oakerson, Brad Williams. Williams.
I'm forgetting somebody else,
but one other woman who I
don't know. Um, but anyway,
it's a great lineup. It's in Las
Vegas. You had been, you know,
running your material, getting ready
for it. I thought as a gift, um,
because you're my wife that,
uh,
I could just go ahead and throw out
there some joke ideas. She's four years.
So what I wanted to do was create
this moment where we have you run this
material right now, cold.
You don't know what it is.
I just wrote it for you and uh, you just
read it and like fucking serious, right?
Yeah. Yeah. You wrote something
for me? Yeah. Isn't that nice?
I already know what it is.
Just don't know.
I don't even say I was saying like,
I think it's not going to guess it's,
I think it's helpful. Okay.
Um, and the, you know,
it's a spouse trying to help a spouse.
So I'll go ahead and play the MC and
then you go ahead and do the bit.
Okay. And fully commit. Please clarify.
All right. And coming to the stage.
Now Ladies and gentlemen,
put your hands together
for Christina. P. Yeah.
Okay, go ahead. Hair.
Um, you like big tits?
Well, I got um, check out these milkers.
These are tits so far,
so good town.
I call this one Milwaukee and this one,
green bay.
These are ripe for all your dairy meat.
Yeah.
Milk. You got it. Cheese, yogurt.
Could you give me till tomorrow?
Why
me?
Okay.
Look at me.
Look at this bitch over here.
She got some tiny little Hungary.
Ted's damn bitch.
You got a gluten allergy or something?
Thanks.
Eat a sandwich.
Skinny little bit.
Sure.
Okay. But you think this is my
voice, like this is how I tell jokes.
Yes. This is your impression of my
aunt. Just keep going. You're killing.
Oh my gosh. Okay. Um,
you're looking up here at these
big old tits and you're wondering,
is that the only big thing on
her? Nope. I got a big puss too.
You can park and an F-150,
a Silverado and a ram in there
and let motor trend decide,
which is the truck of the year.
You know what sad is that like these
are actually decent jokes, like,
like your yearly, you can't
just stop. Okay. Okay. Oh yeah.
My second kid is about to wreck the shop.
My Pussy is in the twin towers and these
babies are hijackers number one and two.
Al Qaeda.
You done fucked up downtown again.
Oh,
I love America.
Good night.
[inaudible].
I'm glad you saved it with that last
line because they were upset about you're
insensitive job, but good job. I mean,
I have to say like the jokes were
actually pretty well constructed. I'm,
I'm upset.
Yeah.
I put a lot of time with my second kid is
about to wreck the shot. My postseason,
my pussy is the twin towers and these
babies are hijackers number one and two.
Can I use that? That's pretty good. I
actually liked that. Okay. Oh good. Wow.
Al Qaeda, you done fucked up
downtown again. Yeah. Wow.
How long did this take to
ride this material from you?
About a 35 to 45 seconds.
Look at this bitch over here.
She got some tiny little hungry.
Ted's damn bitch.
You got a gluten allergy or something?
Eat a sandwich. Skinny little bitch.
I have a, I could just hear you in my
head as I was writing this. Yeah. Yeah.
So I just, from what I'm hearing,
you want me to focus more on my tits?
I mean, I think, I think
that's natural. Yeah.
And talk about what you know, that's what
you're saying. Right? What did, you know?
Wow, these are really
great. So what I'm gonna do,
I'm just going to practice tonight and
see if it goes well and then I'll let you
know. Yeah, yeah. I mean, you know, you've
been doing a lot of sets around town.
I think it'd be great if you even said,
uh, my husband wrote some stuff for me.
Jesus Christ. Here's some new stuff I'm
working on. You just pull it out. Yeah.
The sad thing is even your bad jokes are
pretty funny. Oh, thanks. Yeah. I mean,
not the eat a sandwich. You Skinny
Bitch or the yogurt lines. Great.
And how about Milwaukee and green bay? See
the, those are, uh, all those are right.
Dairy towns. Those are cities in Wisconsin
dairy state. Right. Gotcha. Gotcha.
Okay. Yeah. Feel free to swap them out.
You want to call them Madison and Osh
Kosh or whatever? Sure. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a really good, thanks. You're
welcome. Anyways, people can see you.
They probably, I'm, it's already all sold
out, but uh, it was just Ellie's
gone. No, no, I'm talking about
in Vegas. Uh, I don't know because they
give out those tickets last minute. Oh,
do that. No. Should the sign up is already
pretty full on. It's pre, pre done.
And everybody did. Yeah, he did
really great. When did you do this?
There's so funny yesterday. Very
talented. Thanks. Oh, that's not bad.
These aren't terrible. I think it's so
funny that you're complementing it. Well,
I can see good joke writing. I mean
the structure is really good. Yeah.
My Pussy is the twin towers and these
babies are hijackers number one and two.
That's really funny actually.
I do like it.
I know you done fucked up downtown
again. I like that too. It's a little,
it's a little black sounding
for me really. Well,
I don't say you done fucked up again.
You can change the phrasing you done.
You fucked up downtown and get traffic's
fucked up again. Yeah. Thanks. Yeah,
it was really special.
Thanks Tom.
I'm really proud of it and I think you're
going to have a great set as long as
you stick to exactly what I wrote.
Okay. Yeah. Um,
okay. Why don't we just take
a moment here because, uh,
our guests should be arriving shortly
and I want to eat something real quick
after. Usually after.
I know after a big set,
I like to kind of chill for days
after killing Linus. I'm exhausted.
Yeah. All right, well here we go.
We are back in.
People's big dream has come true.
The last time was such a massive success.
Uh,
we never expected it to go.
I mean we always expect to go well,
but it definitely
exceeded our expectations.
We have in marking our to drew list as
it is called since the full list of video
just for you.
He is back doctor
the body pens.
I'm so happy to be here.
I'm so excited now showing the guns
off with a guest who you may introduce.
Yes. My wife, Susan's sitting
behind this. She may yet come in.
I've just mostly excited that she
gets to see the videos with me. Yeah.
So experience these things
with me. Uh, she didn't,
she didn't seem to understand
the importance of the,
the farts to you guys and the
blue are kids at breakfast.
Our kids are visiting us this weekend.
They all came around because
my daughter's in town and uh,
they mentioned at breakfast I was
told them I was coming over there.
All that talks. I'm so excited.
They talk about poo a lot, you know,
uh,
about one of the,
we have a lot of things we want to show
you clips that we've been playing since
you've been on and get your take on that.
But some people you don't understand. I,
I used to get my,
I have to get prostate biopsies regularly
for my prostate cancer and I would
sort of breaking a sweat just walking
around and you're all just off this fuel.
Just like that was exactly like that.
Except we're going to
shoot him a fucking needle.
I bring load of beer.
Plosive yeah.
What is your anxiety? I don't know. On
a scale of one to 10 about an eight,
what are the first things,
I guess we'll get this out of the way.
Somebody emailed and
they wanted us to wait.
Let me just first say how happy I
am to be here. Good to see you guys.
And I and I,
last time I was a little disoriented and
it took me a while to figure out what
the hell was going on. But
now I feel like I, you know,
I know you guys better and
I've been out of your house.
I've used your tushy toilet seat.
Did you use it,
use it or are you just, I just, it'd
be held. Behold the tushy toilets.
I mean the name just south of La.
I got a new one.
We're actually swapping it out.
The new one gets said we've got
to get curls dinner together.
I know we did since we last ride day,
we've got to get crawl over here to test
these things because he says, you know,
cleaning his mass is like trying to take
peanut butter out of shag carpet. Yeah.
And so, so this would be, this
could be really important for him.
It's very much like that. Go with
it. And have you tried it before?
I've used those before. Yes. I've,
I use the what's now the London
and New York used to be the,
I forget what it's called,
but it was it sort of a Japanese own
thing and the right and you know we got
into these because we rented a
house for a year from Japanese.
They figured this stuff out.
She had the toto washlet
but she had it hooked up in her house.
It sounds like it's up to a generator.
It's so effected us that when we bought
this house we immediately were like,
day one.
We need to
go back and tell him. I'm
just imagining, here you go.
You got a lot of stuff going on up here.
Yeah,
it's a lot going on again
to quote Corolla, it's like
trying to find Santa Claus.
His mouth down there.
He's been asking me to eat his scrum,
her
to make out with my butthole,
you know,
and like Bay Bay that with her tongue.
Well you know it's going to be clean
because you've had the tushy thing.
Can we wait till she's not
practicing something very weird.
I mean I worry about what the holdup is.
I could make a case.
You're ready against it, please.
Is the case is that, you know,
we got a homeless problem here in Los
Angeles and there's a lot of them saying
to ask a homeless person to do a lot
of fecal contamination of our water and
that oral fecal transmission of disease,
it can be really problematic
for a pregnant lady.
And so if you just happen to go buy one
of those encampments and volatilized
Norovirus, get into your nasal
passage, that stuff's going to be,
I stay away from those places. I
understand that. I just thought it,
but that's one of the
arguments against it. Well,
that's the only accurate I can think of.
Otherwise I just worry
about pregnant women.
I just don't want them to go once
she wants to. She delivered game on.
Thank you doctor [inaudible]
especially with your devices. I mean,
what do you got to worry about?
I'll just do it like the squat and
sit and get it over kind of quick.
You don't know where she lies on her back
over her squat down on her face. Weird.
What about antiseptic,
sir?
You're only watering your be whole still
fills the Clorox wipes or something.
You know rocks. Why? But he's
willing to do it for you.
My Dad wipes with those Clorox
wipes, double kill everything. Well,
he said,
I don't have any bottle age now,
so no cost to me now and nobody,
somebody calls out your theory.
Which one?
I'm going to show it to you. Okay,
let's do it. Gosh. Uh, hey dog hunts.
The episode of Dr Drew May have been one
of the best I ever heard on your mom's
house. However, I do feel that doctor
drew did make one egregious claim weight.
I couldn't sit back and
accept. Yeah, absolutely.
Pushes out the farts inspired by his
hot take and the claim by my beloved
girlfriend Jean,
that I may fart too much.
I set out on a personal case study
to inspect my own farming habits.
Even pregnant.
You're still good with this gesture on
supposed to make you want to vomit. Good.
The best part is that we're asking
a man who so overqualified. I know.
Well,
listen to what this guy said.
He goes after farts never gets
old when you're a boy, a man.
After keeping a detailed daily
journal for over three weeks,
a fart counts and patterns.
I found an introspective study into
your fire and Brown habits can be quite
light. Oh, that's interesting. First I
found that I fart about 17 times a day,
which by many standards is
above a little bit. Yeah,
it feels good to be above
average at something.
Even if this means I may be
more statistically likely
to clear you to actually
deliver. Right now you're going 17
healthy movement. Second, I
found after a fudge baby birth,
my farts were relatively dormant and
less agitated by food or another brown.
In my findings,
a looming brown was always good for
several warning blast until the log was
dropped and subsequently cut
by my urine and conclusion.
I can say with confidence,
poop does push the farts out.
When you're pushing poops out, farts
get pushed out to, come on now.
Talk me up. I mean, this is
Billie Jean who wrote in for that.
It's got to be true.
But
I mean this is a great advancement
in the world of scientific clinical
observation.
And I'm so grateful
I, you know, I, maybe I didn't
get into it deep enough last time.
Where'd it go further?
Which is that everybody's
a little different when it
comes to their farts. Okay.
Okay.
I mean we're having a serious
conversation is the best thing.
Just bodily form have somebody so cool.
So here's the deal.
Some of it is from swallowed air, right?
Some people are very prone to that.
They swallow that area.
It really gets through.
But there's other people that it's the
bacterial gas production than I tragedies
splitting of nitrogen by
the bacteria in the colon.
And that's what gives the smell and but
also at some people produce the gas too.
So some people, it's what they
eat. And with the bacterial Sorta,
the colonic sort of bacterial
flora is doing right and what that,
what that floor is doing.
I can it be effected by bulk and stuff.
He had a lot of good bulk in your diet.
You might be sort of quieting things down
a little bit. But if you're balanced,
stirred, and even at the right
locations, fiber, farmers, citrucel,
metamucil,
stuff like that issue and that you gotta
keep well now with all that in your
body and your abdomen, don't you have
to keep things kind of vegetables
for a praying lady?
I take amazing.
Is it time for me then you have to get
harassed. Burt before you eat yours.
I've done it. I've done
it. Okay, that's good.
It's a lot cleaner and as a man
we really don't. We sorta like,
okay, let's go. Let's go. What do you like
us to do? All right, where do we do it?
You want it to really shower?
He just did it.
And also like more than once. Let's
not say like I did it. Yeah. So shoves.
He liked it. So why do you think
she'd return the face once in a while?
I mean the state, the state, sort of
my inner dialogue coming out, I get it,
but know sort of standing over her sounds
like you're going to produce something
more than
just super freak her out.
Why don't we start like
never shower something easy.
I'm thinking maybe in the change my diet
position laying on my back. Yeah, yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I can get in the dog for you dog.
Hideous.
I look hideous in all day and just not
a good guy with what women put aside to
love their mad, just let me
know. I know it's not fair.
It's really both of us got these wonderful
looking women and which like what are
they doing? Well, it's a matter with
them. I also think like I'm, you know,
I'm not the greatest at this,
but I know people who are so some guys
who are so far down the line on there
physically so unappealing and they
have these standards where you're like,
are you insane? Why do they
like it's offensive. Yeah.
They're like, no fat chicks,
Bro.
I'm like your three 50 this is biological.
Yes. Do you really want to hear it? Well,
it's that the way we've evolved is males,
if you evolutionary biological,
sort of an evolutionary psychology sort
of descriptions are sort of just so
right,
because you can't really study them
because there's no way to turn back the
clock. Right. Where the people haven't
found great ways to study it. So,
and please don't tell me all the
different ways that people do steady.
I know there's things out there to help.
I understand this.
So males have generally,
because we don't have to invest
so much biologically in a child,
we could just drop and go drop it go.
Which is what your new anal play.
There's going to be called
scrum master,
Christina.
Uh,
we tend to be more interested in
fertility for Kennedy and health and so
genetic, genetic, uh, you know, good
genes we're looking for good. Yeah.
And the females also are looking for
that and sort of have a different
relationship with guys that give them
the good genes but are mostly looking for
guys that can provide resources and
stability in an environment where yeah,
we're a child could be brought
on. Yeah. Yeah. Thus the house,
the Fart pill.
Yeah. Safety's last name means
a Segura is what? Safety safe.
Sure. Yeah. That was his dad though.
Not, yeah, that's true. Yeah.
But he's much like his father,
which is wow.
Yeah. You've mentioned, yeah, you did.
Like you do? Like is that better than him?
Well, I've said that. He just
texted me. He let me see. He did.
Oh, he just facetime yesterday facetimed
me from a handicap stall. Uh, he was like,
look how much room I have this
shit in here. Where'd you get that?
Where'd you get the way you are?
I don't understand it. Yeah.
It's hard to figure out. Um, I want
to jump right in. Jump right in. This,
we have so much.
You do. I've tried it. I've
tried to like smoke screen.
We're going to ease into it. Okay.
Yeah. That's what you said last time.
First one of those words,
the first one that was in the news.
You may have caught wind of this one,
but I just wanted to get your take on it.
This lady who you may or may not
have heard about recently in the news
guys, this woman says she came
from Florida to find love.
Now she claims a man she's accused of
stalking is her soul mate because of her
superstitious beliefs and a particular
number following the number 33 I used to
wake up every day and every night at
three 33 was always three 33 three
Jacqueline Claire added
tied to the number 33?
No,
this woman went from Florida.
How did you, you know this story?
She texted this man who she had gone on
one date with 65,000 times I heard about
the or something like that.
Um, and then they, you know,
they arrested her and then she actually,
they gave her like a mini press
conference, which I thought was unusual,
but why Tom? She seems fine. Welcome to
the world of world news now. Yeah. Yeah.
Your, your show is going to become
a major news outlets. Don't worry.
That's what led her right
to a paradise valley businessman.
She met on the dating app. Look,
then I find out he does stuff with the
Dead Sea. The Dead Sea has 33% salt in it.
The common ground between the two.
Same birthday,
convincing her even more
that he's her match.
Oh boy. Do you think that something's
going on with her? It's no perfectly
normal. Perfectly natural. But are
you talking about Tom, we just,
you just told me you want to stand over
your wife with your pants on with this
lady. Cause I feel like the
eyes are very revealing.
Very right. You see that right?
So there's a psychotic process,
right?
She's not connected to reality and there's
a sort of an OCD thing going on here.
I feel a little guilty talking about this
one cause I'm going to give a talk on
stigma and Oct.
I'll write him a couple of months,
maybe around the same week
you air this thing. Uh,
and so I hate to make fun of this
woman as you guys make fun. We will.
I know it makes me feel bad, but the, the,
the inability to stop the preoccupations
you see it just rolls and rolls and
expands and expands and this kind of a
psychotic process to it, right? She's,
she doesn't even like sort of acknowledge
that this is a problem here. Right. Uh,
and then the obsessive compulsive quality
to it and then the compulsive behavior
of texting a billion times, that kind
of thing. She's medication. Yeah.
Very bad thing.
Maybe maybe the separate call
exposure between the two birthday,
convincing her court documents reveal.
She texted him 65
many of those messages show disturbing
delusions of murder also to,
to process. Like if
somebody said, you know,
you did the 65,000 times and she
responded with it. That's it.
I thought it was more like, so she's
not connected. Yeah. Not In this world.
Yeah. And then then they, they
called it delusional, you know,
the newspaper just said
that and she's right.
This is a delusion delusional person.
Yeah.
So mid the sometimes schizophrenia can
have certain amount of OCD type quality
to it. That was voting.
Yeah. What it meant,
the idea that these are the
newscasters are treating her like news.
Like, oh no. Like she's rational.
Like asking her these questions,
she's going to act rashly when they
know she's not. Yeah. I always,
I am very disturbed by the
lack of sophistication when
it comes to mental health.
That, you know, I mean, it's
like, honey, have you been, Ooh,
behave even.
Here's the questions you would
ask somebody that you go,
have you been hospitalized before?
Have you been able to manage work?
Have you had, do you have
[inaudible] Jeff obtrusive thoughts?
Have you ever thought that these things
might be problematic as opposed to
really, you love him? Tell us about
that. Like, can you fucking kidding me?
He's like,
give me a break.
That's what we were kind of amused by
as the press conference for women that
clearly just needs medical care.
I feel like I've seen the same look in
an interview with like a psychopathic
killer who's delusional and detached.
It may be,
I don't think you can see he can't read
a lot, but just somebody kind of, Oh,
I've discovered something
called the uncanny valley.
You've heard of this? No. Oh,
you guys love this. Oh yeah, so, and she
makes me think of that when I look at her,
which is that, when is this comes
out of the world of robotics.
So cause I was thinking about stigma,
why it occurs.
I'm doing some research on it and
I came upon the uncanny valley,
enrolled the world of
robotics and virtual reality.
As you make humanoid, let's call them
robots more and more and more lifelike.
We like them like them, like them, like
them till they get really nearly human.
And then we're repulsed.
We get these called the uncanny
valley where this uncanny repulsion.
And look at her, she's like, she's
like, she looks like a human being,
but there's something uncannily
like disturbing. I was like,
Oh man, but we should feel bad
for her. Not just be disturbed.
We should like honey, come,
come with us. Come on now. Yeah,
but we get this uncanny discussed
and discussed. Is it fear? Is it,
it's all of the above.
Why not jump to empathy?
Much like on my hands what I'm saying,
like when he was,
when he watches a video, your theory,
you're going to take getting injured.
Why instead of empathy
does my husband laugh.
I am still to this day traumatized and
confused by the guy in the garage car
where I know he had his legs amputated.
If he survived and he survived,
we find out he's from you have legs.
Yeah, he has legs. What? Yeah, he does.
Do they work?
I mean that was the one that was just
maybe we should show Susan that fit and
confused cause I was traumatized watching.
I knew what was coming and watching
it and then confused when the laughter
ensued between you too.
It wasn't just Oh yes,
Oh yes you did.
Because that's because your reaction was
when there was laughter and nonetheless
there was mirth.
There was birth and I was confused by it.
I was confused by the heads up.
Disturb made a traumatize me more now
I was listening to an interview with
Johnny Knoxville and he was saying,
you know,
they film his reaction
after he's been hurt.
Now I think the audience feels safe
to laugh because we know he's okay.
You know he's going to get medical
treatment even if he cracks a rib. Yeah,
I mean that's what we,
that's what we like the three
stooges and that's male humor.
We like to see people get hurt that
don't really get hurt. You know,
we've got people banging
somebody on the head.
If I took a mal and banged on the head
and it wouldn't be just, Oh, it would be,
oh, we gotta go to the hospital now
and you might never be the same.
It's like that's how there has been a
really starts rolling. Oh No. Oh No.
What's happening? What's happening?
Okay. It's a parachute or
these paratroopers. Are these the
weekend ones? Yeah. Military. Yeah,
but see empathy. Joy. What do
you land on the alligators?
The scream is funny. That
sounds funny. Scream the sound.
Not the connection to what's happening
is another layer to my experience here
today,
which is sort of like,
I'm watching myself a little
more clearly and I'm seeing that.
I'm laughing at things.
I should not be laughing.
The brown side of the forest,
I the one with the,
Oh, my husband loves these murder
shows. Like the first word report.
Interesting. Murder Porn.
Is it a women's thing?
This one is 24. Seven. What's
your favorite? Favorite?
What? Murder Porn? No, I love
crime shows. I like thrillers.
I know what I'm saying. Like so any
I can watch. Do you like the mystery?
The mystery unraveling? I like
solving the crime. Like a evil genius.
I don't know if you saw that. My kids are
watching it. It's fantastic. Yeah. Right.
And it's you putting together the layers
of what's connected and that, you know,
I like,
I like the detective aspect.
Why not figure out how
photosynthesis works or something
with a dead person.
I'm also fascinated by
human behavior and uh,
I've always been interested in
psychology and talk. To be fair,
as I know you somewhat now you are
not interested in human behavior.
You're interested in abnormal human.
That's true. That's true. That's true.
Very abnormal or abnormal.
The more I'm fascinated,
but I don't know why
I'm interested in that.
Here's my theory because I
watch him watching these shows.
Tom's actually be feeling ashamed now.
That's a whole dynamic
is the gossip.
And then what did she say?
And then he did that in his house.
He's got two sisters,
so he got rewarded by that stuff.
So that element came in. Yeah.
You're like gossiping.
I do. I find that very,
very common. Almost unheard of. No, no.
I'm going up to not happen among comics.
Car, super gossipy about
especially about other comics,
about things happening in
our business. Yeah. Yeah.
I almost don't call that gossipy. It's
Sorta like you love tear each other down.
It's envy bore the gossip.
I honestly,
my favorite role in that is the listening.
It's not,
I'm not a big like call everyone
up and talk about everyone,
but I like being the listening device
to others. Somehow that seems better.
Yeah.
He enjoys hearing the story unfold.
Like I'm not very good with details and
stories and I know that you don't like
that tone.
That's true.
I do like storytelling is a good
skill to be comedic skill too.
So it's very, I have very different
parents when it comes to storytelling.
My mother is very good at
detailed storytelling and
her father is horrific at it.
Well, you just told a great story
he did during his face chat.
At least he sets it up, right man. Most
of his stories when he could be like his,
the difference would be like the guy
robbed the place and then that's it.
He'll be like, I was in the store and
then my mom will be like, I was in there,
I was in line. I felt this guy
come in and he was weird. You know,
a woman in front of me. It was breaking
a 20. Yeah, she was wearing a face shield
and you'll be like, did that
happen to yeah. And you're like,
why are you fucking leaving all this out?
Like that's how he tells the story.
Okay. Anyway. All right, let's jump
into the, uh, there's so much. Oh yeah.
This guy is really cool.
Oh, I get your take on him.
I want an adult. How do you in my lap
right now, under 26 right now, no frills,
no big titties and intelligence.
I don't care. She's a hood rat,
punk rock or any kind of anything.
As long as she's hot in here right
now in my 37 year old Dick Right now.
Right now. Right now. Right now, right
now. Right now. Right. No worries.
Oh Geez. He's out of
drugs still. Well or no,
this guy's got it going on.
I'm sure if I should talk to her.
She's like that all the time.
It's very helpful. I mean,
we suspected that something's going on.
He could have the grinding
of the teeth a little bit.
The per separation right now,
right now, right now. Right now,
I didn't know if it was drugs or
mental illness. It can be both.
It's impossible at different spend time
many times and had some people get hyper
become hypersexual on stimulants
and some people have shut off.
If you have the mental illness
combined with a stimulant, then it's,
then it can go into overdrive and
for sure it could, but it's again,
it's hard to predict which way
you're going to go. We, we've,
we discussed this last time I seen him
like we saw a lot of stimulant type stuff.
He's real, he's got it going
on. He's somebody who admire
and emulate. Definitely.
If you're going to set up your
Tinder account, that's what you want.
Hang behind it.
You want to do.
I haven't visited that this clip in
a while so I forget what he could.
I think he gets into more
never having anything is everybody
else gets way he'd agree here. Beers,
use the research on Calamari and I put
it out eight months ago and then you just
go with that. Oh, why won't you go with
me? I don't need that question answered.
I need right now. Right
now. Right now. Right
CD treatment. You think you still are.
You guys always, she'll be dead people.
Dead people.
So the repetition is severing
these nonsensical even
that some of the times that
rhyming stuff, that weird run weird.
Did you see that? A lot of me,
but sometimes it makes me think you know,
but he's in real trouble. Keep going.
I want to say he's okay. He's
in real trouble. Keep going,
having to order, give him food away
to the homeless. I think I deserve it.
I think I'm entitled Bloke and
I think that I deserve it. Now.
I'm not going to believe in
your guide or any nonsense.
I'm not going to believe in fate.
And either I just want to hear right now,
right now, right now,
right now. Right now.
So he also, uh, he also tied in his, um,
his own behavior to deserving it.
He said, yeah, he's been a give
to homeless people, but I, I'm trying
to, I'm really trying to figure this out.
Why he might have norovirus.
No, he'd be vomiting then. Uh,
I'm sure you'll have
the footage like that.
Ma My wouldn't know why the no shirt and,
and why he said No.
The common things is
discovered on this show.
We find a lot of guys with no shoe PCP
will make you store your clothes off if
that's Oh yeah.
It's still around.
And Mtma XTO someone said good to
see people do that. People. Yeah,
but when you go whack on people to do
it first year, just around the street,
three close, cause it's kind of a manic
manias main historic the clothes off.
Remember that guy was the pony guy that
out of San Diego masturbating out on the
corner. Oh, you haven't
seen that footage? Love
they pony the guy, the guy that did that
video about the yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I know who you're talking about.
The South Park picked up a little
cartoon about change the world,
but he was severely manic,
psychotic severely and he was on the
street corner screaming at everybody was
closed off masturbating. That's
as is the custom. It was pristine.
It was swept away.
Can we that now she is laughing at,
I know she claimed she didn't laugh
at that. You're taking it seriously.
I can't tell you why this makes me
laugh. My mother, who was mentally ill,
ironically worked for a psychiatrist
growing up and we would get these calls in
the middle of the night,
um,
that is running down the street called
the pet team. And so I knew her.
I knew from very early age,
like how that works. It just,
it tickles me in an area from childhood.
I need to hear a lot more about that.
But first this guy,
there's,
there's a way he's sitting there that
makes me think he might be lying on his
stomach and he said he hadn't had
any sex in five years or something.
Did you say that up here?
I can pay. He looks for me.
I used to guys look at that when
they like paraplegic, you know,
sort of up on their elbows.
Maybe water.
I think I deserve it. I think I'm
entitled Bloke and I think that has the,
right now, I'm not going to
believe in your guide or any, no.
My slide down.
Putting up on his elbows.
Yeah, under the age of 26
because it tell him my research,
the father is 35 to 55 it could have
been longer. Have longer telomeres,
intelligence, more inner.
We need to get rid of it.
And like we need to get rid
of incest and pedophilia.
We need to get rid of it right now.
Right now. Right now. Right now. That's
right. And there's one last thing.
Oh, you're only having sex.
You're telling Murray's abundant.
You're just going to get
stressed and anger and,
and make everybody depressed and stressed
and angry as you were with the guy and
just go by and later in
life you have cancer.
I want a hottie in my lap right
now. Right now. Right now.
Right now he can old big hits.
Doesn't matter what subculture right here,
right now in Spokane, right now to
go out with me on a date right now.
Yeah. Oh, well he's give their address.
He also put out a video that I'm,
I don't have it queued up,
but where he offered to take a woman to
dinner and give her a thousand dollars
just to go to dinner to go to dinner.
But he also wanted it to be somebody
who was perhaps willing to have a family
with him after it pays $1,000.
Yes. There, you know, uh,
who was I talking to?
One of the radio show or something I'm
doing where we interacted with somebody
that was like, it's such a
prostitute and she said a, he's guys,
we'll just pay just to hang out.
Yeah. That's kind of, yeah, eh.
She's got a ladder. Gee, I don't think so.
It'd be hard to get that engine to adapt.
So what kind of mental illness your mouth
have? Oh, eh, she was borderline. Ooh.
And then later psychotic.
But we didn't know early in the eighth
has shoes, which I'm pills later.
Is that the psychosis? Probably Kim is
Shuttin. She um, oh, she got depressed.
She got sick with cancer and then she
slowly became more and more of a shut in
and by the hills that, huh? I
must have been pink. I don't know.
Doctors do that Turner. Yeah,
some something's doing. Uh,
but anyways, entertaining.
That's one way of putting it.
Talked to my therapist is
that only recently came to
know that that's borderline
disorder or did you always
know? No, I, I only,
I knew 10 years ago when I got into
therapy and my shrank was like,
I have a theory. Yeah. Your mother
might've been. And I'm like, no, that's,
that sounds about right.
Yeah.
So it's so surprising to me how few
people really understand what that is.
I was talking to somebody the
other day, I'm like, no, no.
That's borderline disorder.
Oh No. It's very clear to me.
People seem to understand narcissism,
but they don't understand borderline
portal adds a little harder to,
to undertake. Yes. From the beginning.
Yeah. I guess it's a more covert racism.
I think you see it, it's
kind of more apparent. Yeah.
And somebody can say
something and be like, see,
that's super nice and borders
are good at sort of drag.
He's getting you in the queue,
sucking you in and all of a sudden
the thing starts spinning around.
And the appearance of being
charming and normal try. Yeah.
Shit. Yeah. Was real fun.
Funny. I feel it was funny. Yeah.
You can say, I feel bad for brothers.
They're their own worst enemy. They really
are. Their biggest fear is abandonment.
And ironically they push everybody,
right?
So they suck you in and
they get you super close,
they build you up and then
they cut you down. So you,
so you either you're either all good or
all bad at all times and if you're all
good, you're going to bandage. They make
you all bad and then they abandoned you.
That sounds about right. So, yeah,
that's why I was down the comedian. Yeah,
it's good. It's gotta come from
somewhere. Oh Gosh. Yes. Oh boy.
Processed a Yay. Um, so PCP,
that's what we're thinking on this guy.
I'm thinking still thinking stimulants.
Stimulants. Yeah. Maybe I'm
doing maybe MDM, ecstasy.
Interesting. Come on topic.
We were the tough, yeah.
What? You give me a rough one.
Hit me a rough one. Okay. Yeah.
Oh, what'd you think? Oh Jesus.
Just the way he's,
Oh gosh.
Hi.
I'm looking for a white lady.
It's tattoo and dominant and be willing
to put me in a dress and beat the shit
out of me. Call me. I'm going to
see she had three months street.
Okay.
Can
Fremont CC Jim Again?
You skipped and white bitch.
It's what I'm looking for is a stupid
care to like bitch that put me in a dress
and shit.
Call me 22 and wait, wait,
slut.
No,
I've never kind of really
bunched up on that way.
That is that he or she,
he, but what are you,
things are so bad for them really. Then
again, when he starts calling of the,
it was interesting because he started
submissive. Yeah. Flip to like,
is he not [inaudible] whatever it is.
I was having empathy until he
started that stuff that I was just,
yes, I can. Horrible feeling in my chest,
Mike Disgust and then
pain and misery and uh,
and then watching her glee and delight.
Yeah.
Feeling that way is really disturbing.
Really like look at her actually.
She's like, yeah. What? What
else? What else? What else?
Horrible you feeling in your stomach
so hard. It's so horrible. So horrible.
You're laughing at me. Sexual
fetish that we're seeing. Well, no,
that's, I don't think they, I wouldn't
say quite that lightly. That's a,
that's not a great, happy
person. That looks good. I mean,
that's an unhappy, horrible, horrible
life. You think so. Sure to be. Why?
Just because he wants to be beat and
everything. Did you catch you feel,
it seems like a normal guy to me.
You're saying
you're good life and then be
had the shit beat out of him.
Cause that, yeah, but some
people, is that always okay?
There's always in pop culture, let's say
in movies and I've heard it, you know,
thrown around by no,
not experts that the idea that um,
powerful people,
yes, the people didn't engage that
provide those services will say that,
that oftentimes are servicing people that,
that are success can't be
submissive in their life.
And this is just sort of
the way they act that out.
And so when they become submissive with,
by hiring someone is that they're
unhappy or they really just,
is it like a harmless thing? This
guy's a CEO, clearly have some company,
this is the president of Chevron. You
didn't remember it was Brooks brothers.
I guess I see that. I see the button
down. Shirt on. I'm just talking about it.
Yeah.
Oil Man there.
Um,
uh,
it's more of the compartmentalization
of trauma. Ooh. Right.
And so if somebody is a,
CEO's have a high probability to be
narcissistic and all the nurses and as a
response to trauma and then
when you've been traumatized,
you're using this pseudo self
to keep yourself pumped up.
There's a part of yourself you leave
behind that then get service through
reenactment of the trauma. Does
that make sense? It does make sense.
And reenacting the trauma can
be playful and fun and okay.
It's certainly doesn't fix the trauma.
It doesn't help the trauma.
And sometimes your retraumatized it's
going to be, we can make things worse,
but it's all that
compartmentalization of trauma
and, and, and this gentleman
who will call a non CEO,
there's probably just a big
compartment of trauma that he lives.
Yeah, he sort of, Eh, yeah, he started
in it. Right? I think that's true.
Yeah.
He sort of looks like he's like never
made it out and to compartmentalize the
sexualization of this,
he makes it a sexual fetish
and then it's something I will,
maybe he was sexually abused as
a kid or something that right.
Just physically you can
I ask you, uh, your,
your take on something that we were
talking about? Some reason I just,
I've learned it to read you guys and this,
two things now I've got very,
very disturbing one is the impish
smile there. The corner of Tom's mouth.
There occasionally appears. And the
other is Christina, which is great. Yes.
Then what
I see you suffering.
Go ahead.
No. Yeah. When you pointed out that I,
I'm a fan or I'm very into abnormal human.
Yes. Yes. You like
that. That's disturbing.
It does that disturb me? Uh, okay. Cause
those are two different questions. Yeah,
that's true. That's true. Uh,
does not disturb me. Okay.
Uh, I don't find it normal.
Yeah. I find it maybe a little bit
worrisome. It is a little worrisome.
Ah, I always worry. Yeah.
I've had lots of friends that have
been like that and they're like, well,
I love reading novels about
serial killers. I go, really?
Why? It's like, really?
Tell me why none of it's ever borne fruit
now. I've never been able to find it.
He sort of is, you're fine.
Any pattern where I'm like,
oh, that's why they do that.
I just, I've never, and it just, it just
strikes me as like, why? Yeah, me too.
So why, why is so dark? The dark side of
the force? Why are you there with him?
It's so disturbing to you.
I don't like the murder stuff.
And the reason I think it's funny that
he says he doesn't care about the murder
stuff. He just, he likes the APP. Makes
me laugh. I'll look it up. The hold too.
It doesn't necessarily, maybe you will
after. I like doing all this stuff.
I think part of this is like a
mad at my mom maybe or something.
And this is a way that you deal with
that. Yeah, I have. So then you are,
you're Bob. The way he would come after
me when I've started feeling better,
but I know you can handle it.
But the reason I feel comfortable laughing
at you is because you're professional
and you know what I do. I do remember
being exhausted by the end of last show.
I do remember that. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
I think I remember you saying
that emotionally exhausted.
I think getting together the same feeling
in my gut. Here's a good one. Oh good.
Thank you. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh,
I just saw our first reaction every time.
It's all I got to work there.
What is she doing? She's rubbing. Yeah.
No, I don't pull, you know what?
I don't believe her. No. Oh,
I think she's doing that for some, like
business likes to, to attract vampire,
you know what I mean? Some people that
are into that kind of fetishy stuffs.
I bet.
Yeah. And I just wanted
to share with all of you,
I felt the need to share me placing
menstrual blood all over my face and what
power it holds for us as women to fully
own this part of self that we have been
shamed.
Well, whatever it was, I didn't believe
it is sick. You didn't believe in a say.
Yeah. The first I went out for a
thing and I went, wait, wait, wait.
She's doing it for a reason.
But also it could be a bit, um,
and attention seeking reason. It's
sort of stuff as it's, it's some,
it's like either it goes under either,
hey,
I provide fetish services and here's
one of them are very, come get me.
Or this is an artistic happening,
you know,
as artistic expression or in her case
it's a political move thing. So, right.
Reclaiming the blood and through
reclaiming it to get worse, show cycle.
No fully allowed me to embody
like everything that I was,
it fully allowed me to have the freedom
to be able to express who I was in every
way.
It mean to me
this, um, this justification, this,
but explanation for it sounds
like nonsense. Total bullshit.
Total cause she's just an APP. It's all,
it's all bullshit. Bullshit, bullshit,
bullshit, bullshit. But I thought that
the, now she could be borderline, right?
Because, because my original take on
the blood was like, oh, that's bullshit.
And then as she's talking, well that's
bullshit too. So there's no real there.
There. Oh, borderline. Sometimes I'm not,
I don't know her. I'm not calling her out.
She seems lovely. Whatever is world story
stuff where you find all your stuff,
people send it from everywhere.
Oh my God. Oh my gosh. Um, yeah.
And so, uh, the, it has that feel of Sar
posted it like look at this stupid bet.
Yeah.
By putting it in sports media,
I really found it just a kind of,
gave an invitation to people to be able
to know that it's okay to share this
part of yourself and
that it's not terrible,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Yeah. Bullshit. Whatever.
I don't know what her motivation
is. Good. I can't tell. Yeah. Um,
Worldstar I didn't even put that together.
Horrible.
You know, I've been trying to play, we're
looking all over for it. Is it here?
I wanted to play for him.
That other guy breaking his leg.
Oh No. Oh Wow. A genuine response to this.
How about that? Hey, so let me see it.
I'm interested now to what I was going
to tell you. It's kind of a side note.
It's,
it'll do Braille.
I was listening to a podcast about the
me too movement yesterday. Yes, yes.
And there's, um, you know, millennials
and she goes, before the podcast began,
she goes, I just want to give
a trigger warning. Oh boy,
you're listening to this. You
might be triggered. And I was like,
where are we going with this?
I thought that I thought we'd sort of
move through that. Yeah. I've just,
I've discovered I spent some time with
millennials this week, uh, and to,
to big shocking things jumped out
at me. One, they do not use condoms.
Zero. Zero. What? I was
talking to the teen mom on,
it's about two 20 kids in
there and I was like, hey,
we're talking about the rise in STI
is, and I go, you know, safe sex.
I could see their eyes kind of glaze
over. I go, condom use nothing. I go,
how many of you use condoms?
I just raise your hand.
Not one hand went up that one
hand, one hand. I was like, oh,
I need to start love lineup again.
They're a snapchat page
or podcast or something.
So that one jumped out at me and then
I've decided that millennials all have the
dunning Kruger Syndrome. What's that? Oh,
I thought Christina would
know that when we immediately,
Denny Krueger is essentially a cognitive
distortion where you think you know
more than you do or you think
you're better than you are.
It's what essentially gives people the
ability to get up at American idol and
sing like crap and then say,
I understand it's not a great,
so that's done in Kruger.
It's actually a syndrome. And,
and people have varying degrees of this
done in Kruger phenomenon based on their
essentially lack of real knowledge because
they don't know how much they don't
know. Right. They never,
it's like a lack of exposure to depth
and therefore they feel like they know
everything cause they're exposed to the
phone, they can get fired. Everything.
It's reading the whole book.
They're just going to,
they're not having any spiritual learning.
They're just looking at a bunch of facts
and then they forgetting them and they,
and they all think they know a lot more
than they do. So it's done in Kruger. Wow.
So they are sexually active. I mean,
they're not just a bunch of pure puritan.
I know they're not using condoms, they're
just not. And there's an opposite.
Dunning Kruger or see this,
the converse of the dunning
Kruger is the imposter effect.
People that have large,
um,
tremendous amount of expertise
often feel like an imposter.
Most people in professions
to sorta go through a phase,
at least a phase like that.
Yeah. So, wow, it's fascinating.
Or Sti is just rampant,
just going up there,
going up words if we're everyone got that.
But as we get the vaccine now,
so it's not that big a deal,
but it's a no Korea and syphilis
going way up. Well it's treatable.
Thankfully for now. I mean they're,
they're getting resistance. You know,
syphilis is a, is a Shanker that goes
away and it comes back and surprise.
You don't have like nasty pictures
like that for me to the medical grows.
Yeah. Which is confusing. Again, I don't,
I don't get that you guys are
novelists in so many ways. Uh, but,
but uh, the simplest goes away and goes
inside and that's when it does, you're,
it's damaged. Correct. Right,
right. It'll make you crazy.
Raw Nature. Right. Well that's
the theory we do. We don't know.
I think that's probably a good one.
Cause he, cause he, he was always sick,
you know,
forever.
And then all of a sudden it's neurological
deterioration and what makes me
absolutely insane. Does your audience
know about your background in philosophy?
Okay. Um, is that people go, oh, well his,
his philosophy was so negative and
so disturbing. It drove him crazy.
Are you kidding me?
There's never been a case of psychosis
caused by philosophy or a belief system
or a challenging problem of some type.
It's like mental illness, illness,
a brain disorder. Did you ever
call our friends at pel? No.
Don't bring,
oh,
Jesus. Oh Man. Whatever's going to
happen. It's not going to be good. Uh,
oh no.
Oh No.
Uh, you know what? I'm having
a strange reaction. Yeah.
It's not as bad as it could've been.
Yeah.
I thought he was going to lose his legs
because that car rolled over him and,
and that truck sort of metal hit him.
He would lost his legs,
but the scream is funny.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm here with you.
It's dark side of the forest,
Georgia guys.
She's a funny screen without a
single shift or pool or anything
that make, why is that? Like, I
don't like, I know he's in pain.
There was no bounces back.
Hoe knows he's already
walking before the surgery.
It's made an open fracture there.
Yeah.
Okay.
When I add,
oh no.
Are you thirsty?
Oh my God.
I don't want to breast feed.
You
watch
suck me dry.
Your wife seems to like it. Susie
may get out of this wall. Oh,
thirsty.
Oh Wow.
Is He, is he, is he producing milk? No,
but they're pretty nice nips, right?
Men lack 10. Yeah, it's
called galactorrhea then.
But I mean if you're on certain
medications, work on those nips.
You really got to get on him right. To
make the blog bill. Bill come out. Yeah.
You want to try?
Wait, what's wrong with
this manager? This one?
I mean, something's going on with
him, right? You go out with him. Uh,
it makes me, I'm going to
guess, Oh, I don't know.
But it feels like a gender issue,
right?
Like he's identifying with the mom and
stuff and he wants to be that interesting.
And I'm wondering if he's on hormones and
maybe sort of making his way that way.
This is his sexual piece of that.
Now this is one of the earliest,
your most vulnerable oldest clips.
Yeah.
What do people have been saying
and thinking about it just,
they just love it early.
Just gnarly. Yeah,
but he seems very, I, he
seems quite at ease with all
of it. Very good at it. Yeah.
He's a so he doesn't bother him.
He likes what he likes. Oh yeah.
I don't feel bad than the
normal your mom's house way
does it normally.
I feel so sad for these people,
but I noticed there's
something about myself.
I can't get my hands away from
my friends cause I'm so ashamed.
Why are you so sure your shame?
No shame being here with you today.
Cause I kind of know him. I
know what's coming. I know
it's shameful thing is I, I,
I actually have empathy for
these people too and I feel like,
I just think the behavior silly,
the behaviors funny yet,
even though we have empathy
in, okay. Yeah, the behaviors.
Silly zoom.
You think of this guy?
My name's Jeremiah. You Shipman
I'm looking for girls for pussy.
Okay.
There you go.
Preclinical cause you're in a FACA
is you're looking for some action.
They live in Missouri.
Please
call me at one to five or
seven or text me at one six,
three.
I just, to me that's
just desperation. Yeah.
But I also think there's
something interesting with
the voice level in the eyes.
You know it's like the voice is like,
it's like this whisper but it
doesn't seem like he's whispering.
Seems like he's talking now I'm imagining,
I'm imagining he's really fat.
Oh really?
And there may be like a
respiratory piece of this. Oh okay.
You know what I'm saying? I was like he's
not fully because the camera's awesome.
Right?
I don't think his lungs can inflate like
that much or that much weight and the
eyes are really not moving along well.
I'm thinking that looks a little
substance here. We look at that.
Look at the glaze.
Yeah.
Yeah. Kiki. Motherfucker know you are go
sex wait time machine out of beef jerky.
Why? Yeah. Oh what are looking
roll a blunt with her pussy was
so he said he bought belly a sex
swing time machine out of beef jerky.
So now we're getting into
time machine out of beef jerky and he
wants a girl that can roll a blunt with
her pussy was not possible
to sort of aim for your try. Yeah. Re Tom,
you're a dude like goals in life. Yeah.
Yeah.
What do you want me to do? Oh No,
I want it early because that smile,
you're happy to see me
at one six or call me.
Call me. Oh, there's a
good one to fives by.
But maybe just like a really morbidly
obese guy. Yeah. Desperate. Desperate.
A desperate. Yeah. That's the normal
sadness I feel. What's your videos? Yeah.
Well this one will procure up. Hold
on, let me get you something more fun.
But the beef jerky swing,
what am I saying?
This guy's in Burger King.
Fuck.
So He's, he goes in there. He's,
he's really, you know, not,
he's actually over the cash
register, stealing, causing problems.
And then the employees take it the
matter into their own hands. Good.
Oh, that's not good. No,
it's that good. Hold cheese. He's got
like a leg brace on and then they keep,
uh, they came after him. Well,
someone's standing on them right now.
I want his head.
I got a sub.
Do the guy
shows up to get up.
Well,
she was the guy who's standing on his
head to get off so that she can tase him.
You know, she has a taser. Yeah.
That was not good idea. And then that
was just a bystander. You got to slap,
what is it bad or would it be,
if she's tasting the first guy,
let's look is mentally ill,
do
unmoved mover the prime Mary?
What's going on?
Like what's the, what? What's
going on? Is that mental illness?
Well, it could be drugs, right? Like,
yeah, that's always, if your choices,
it's hard to tell to rule out.
That's right.
We got to get a toxicology and
see what's in there and uh,
and see what he's like when he's sober.
He's not totally wow.
It depends what you call
normal, Tom. I mean,
I've started to feel a
lot of things in normal.
They didn't feel that way about an hour
ago. It's physical time with you guys.
I could be, who knows
where I'm at? Had deaf.
Jeez.
It's a little overkill on the tasing.
He goes outside and he just gets
right on his, a little scoot. Scoot.
He gets on his way. What is
that like a scoot for your,
when you have a a leg that though.
Oh, they either think of the scoot.
They've put this chair chair
on wheels. Oh Wow. Yup.
Well he, he needs that. He's got a broken
leg. I'd love to hear how that happened.
The broken leg. A couple really good
ones. There was skiing in the Alps,
I suspect holiday.
I'm really John McAfee's sword.
I remember McAfee antivirus
software. Yes. Yes.
This man became very wealthy.
Oh.
Cause he's one of the early guys that
got in on a software viruses. Yeah.
So he uh, he kinda got
out. He got out of it goes,
I could sit here and do this all day.
I'm in a parallel universe.
I like, time doesn't move anymore.
If I'm going through the wormhole
by, okay, Susan, am I okay? Am I
went pee? No, it's just not good.
She's worried about me. She's worried. I
May, I may have her sit and watch them.
I just add to this business, it's what
you want to see, what they've got,
the long nipples. So you can
see that one. That was great.
I got a first row view of her as
that was playing. She was like, yeah.
So McAfee, I knew she liked that one, was
bought out of his company a while ago,
left with nine figure there,
went down to Belize, um,
and has since um,
been uh,
chased by them for a
murder or to choose by who?
By Belizian authorities or they believe
that he murdered a neighbor. Um,
but I didn't watch this documentary and
then like in the midst of all of all the,
his time that he kind of took over the
town he was in and believes, you know,
the rich guy hired like 20 armed guards,
bought the police, you know, cars
and boats and just craziness,
kinda crazy.
He also got in with some of the
local gals on a fetish of his,
and I wanted to see your Tim doing this.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. How weird is that?
So here's the,
the girls brace yourself.
But those were the first time I was
ashamed. What? Then I got used to it.
But did he have you do,
um, sit on this hammock?
They have my card as a whole 10 a hallmark
and after that he lays down on the
hammock.
Then he m he would cut,
cut a little hole and he would sit there.
That's why he is cause he wanted to have,
like Scott said,
I didn't agree with that one has got
sex. And when you poop in someone. Yeah.
Oh, what'd she call it? Scat. Scat sex.
Scott Seq catchments into to this.
The Scots are particularly bad,
but nursing is so he would have these
girls sit in a hammock with a whole shit
in his mouth. Oh, I'm
sorry. I misunderstood.
I thought she said he would
sit in a no, no, no. Shit and
Herman. No, no, no, no, no, no.
You're telling me they,
they, it's pretty clearly.
I understand where you've kind of heard
that, but yeah, but no, no. Again,
easy money. Great Gig. Great Gig. All
you gotta do is go over the fully, yeah.
Noted here. Let's give, let's
go through it before we discuss.
Hoping someone will easy peasy
you shit in his mouth like that.
That's cute.
I have never had done that before.
And it was an experience
for a man under your butt
to shit in his mouth.
Did he ever have regular
intercore like that? No.
None of that.
That was the only thing I did.
So his only thing was
paying these girls titties.
Was He masturbating when they did this?
They don't get into that,
but I like to just in question
like imagine that he was, um,
that would make sense, right? Because
this is a sexual fetish top level.
Here's the thing, I actually wonder,
well, you know, I'm a pretty open mind.
A different people like in
different things. We know.
Whatever turns you on, fine.
How can somebody get turned on by that,
I mean get turned on a,
how can they even get through? How
can they tolerate it? Yeah. Yeah.
I wonder that too. I mean, how do they
not throw up like instantly, instantly,
you know? I mean, you walk by
and I'm shit and like, yeah.
Or even if they were gonna
shit on his face, he'd be
like, no. He's like, ah, here,
how can he not? Does he get sick too?
I mean, yeah, you could get this is,
this is what I was worried about for
you. Yeah, I know. Yeah, it was right.
That's why I worry about for me, am
I doing it right? She eats my scrum.
You're saying yes, I'm
worried about, and that's not,
we're not in a third world country. You
know, we're here, although these days,
this bus answers starting to become
that. But, uh, for real. All right.
The width of the sanitation
around homelessness. I, I'm,
I'm mortified what's going
to happen this summer and I,
the city is not helping the,
letting people suffer the streets and
there should accumulate a giant piles and
the rats accumulate on those piles and
we are going to have a big infectious
disease problem.
The summer
defecation. Yeah. It's a
huge problem. Wow. Yeah. Um,
and do you think that there's
a probability that when
somebody has a scat sex
issue that it is okay,
Kenna? I don't get as an
orange. I know I don't get it.
I don't get it at all and I,
and I don't,
it's not something you get
into with patients, you know,
at the level I treat patients. Yeah.
What do you mean you don't get into,
they don't admit to it or you just
as a come up and into this stuff?
I'm working out with people
and so I don't, I can't,
it's quite it with anything because I
never have gotten into it and everything.
Yeah, okay. Except somebody
just wildly, you know,
way out into sort of a psychotic state,
which she kind of sounds like he is right.
Running around buying everything
and sir, he's, Oh, he's whacked out.
He sounds kind of wacky. Yeah. And, and I,
and I don't understand where
that comes from. How I had,
we had a love line once we had a
woman that call Dan, she was, hey,
she was a servant for this
kind of thing or whatever.
She was a prostitute essentially when
she said we had a guy who wanted that and
she wouldn't do it.
So he goes,
can we at least put it in this top where
for me to take it home? Yeah, she did.
I met. Wow. We started calling. We called
her Tupperware lady. That ever happened.
I've met,
uh,
I met a couple who does
videos online and they were,
they were at a show and they were telling
me about, you know, they do sex videos,
you know, and they sell them and
uh, one of their fans contacted,
wanted her to shit and mail it to them,
but also one of her to stick to a
specific diet for three days before.
What was the Diet?
She was like,
he just made me eat these certain things
and he was like a hassle. Is it certs?
Yeah.
I don't know. But she goes, I ate
it and then shutting the thing and,
and he sent her like two grand or
something. That's what I'm talking about.
Is it that bad? The women are making
money. Not that catch your Flab,
Christiana here. Is that what you're
saying? I love you to send me to believes.
Is that where no, no. She what?
He wants the Tupperware of job.
He wants the two rather. Yeah.
Got It. Two grand for that.
Did you do it for far less even?
That's easy money.
Tim Horton's lady lady in the,
in the coffee shop last week.
Uh, this sounds familiar. Oh yes. So
she would Duke it out for her yet.
That was extraordinarily extraordinary.
Yeah, that was, that was, yeah,
there she is. Yeah. And
she's really animated.
Love to know what she was fighting
by. Oh, it was about that. She,
they wouldn't let her use the restroom,
which is sorted, nicely dressed,
which I think is a stair right. She's
like [inaudible] mom and here she goes.
There it is. I gotta go. I gotta. I gotta
I got a problem here. Hold out here. Oh,
she is crazy. It's unbelievable.
And then look at this. Look at this.
Yeah. Oh. Unless you
wiped your hands. Wait,
what's your ass that's
arose that I have to, well,
she picks it up on their barriers.
And you haven't seen this
before or you've seen it. Okay.
I figured I'd like Rappaport did a whole
commentary this good. It's pretty good.
He's very funny. I was like,
I saw it on Twitter actually.
Now the readiness was what? She had
that bowel movement ready. Yeah,
and the chamber loaded.
What do you make of all that?
That's why she needed to go to the
bathroom. She's like, she's like,
it's got to happen. If you don't
believe me, this lady's problematic,
uh, to this particular
location. Yeah. You kidding?
This is a difficult person.
You are,
I believe is the trouble that person.
I got to tell you.
I'm really, I understand that and I
understand. You know why people are like,
you need to get out of here.
Yeah.
I always feel like it's so crazy when
anyone is refuse the right to a bathroom.
Well,
what civilized world,
my understanding is what came out of that
episode where they question those two
African American gentleman that were
in the Starbucks was now that everyone
could use a bathroom under any
circumstances. If Starbucks,
that's what I heard the new
policy with [inaudible].
They can't serve you cups of bowel torture
and then be like, you can't shit here.
I know. I mean, that's the
product. That's what, it's amazing.
They let you use the bathroom if you
buy something. Yeah, that's true.
I also think it is,
it's inhumane when you're just out
anywhere and you're like, I need to pee.
Strange should be not here to tell you
what in this town, in southern California,
it's not that bad.
Most places within a couple of hits,
you can find some brilliant boy.
You know what I mean? Usually,
but you can be in New York City,
it's no,
wherever you go for miles
and they're everywhere.
Everyone's got a bathroom there.
Everyone's got that downstairs. I know.
Crappy bathroom by the, by the supplies
was seven months pregnant lady.
I walk in and I'm like,
I'm using your bathroom.
I don't even fucking ask him like it's
happening, dude. I dare you to tell me no.
Yeah, or what do you think?
I want you to look at this.
There's obviously a strapper Krav product,
Christina,
very clearly now because we don't
want to miss any of this gold.
It's coming your way,
but I won't drop a Deuce in public.
That's not happening yet at the all the
time and be all the time. Yes. You know,
what are you think of? We're almost
done. Okay. I'm having a great,
there's a grand finale.
The big for my hands,
my face day. United States, he
knows that he's the Latin. Uh,
so you've been not even
so it's his version of he's
funny. He's funny. Yeah,
he's good. But there's some things going
on with all that I haven't seen yet. No,
you can see them. He's been with the
sauna bed. He's been in the side.
I bet he does. Dentist it's brush
everyday. Deep brush is everyday.
Yes. Stance. It seems a little
bit to lazy, but there's also,
is there something that you
can pick up in his lunch?
Uh,
uh,
Eh,
well he, he's got emphysema, right?
Is that what it, is that a pen?
He's got the clip to his chest, her
microphone and uh, yeah, I know he,
that's a, that's a airway
obstruction. You're hearing
that doll, that sound. It is,
yeah. You guys seem to always give me
somebody with pulmonary problems. Yeah.
Because it sounds so funny. Yeah. Yeah.
There should be a respiratory therapist.
That's the word. The job for you.
Collect gobs of sputum, Alyssa.
That buddy shall people make.
Well,
tell him why we think this is so funny
how the origin of the joke came. Well,
hold on.
I'll get through the rest of it.
Did it? We made it. No white dining. No,
no, no. Go ahead.
Oop. There it is. I mean this is a lot
of sign right there. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Maybe a truck driver maybe. No, I don't
think, I don't think he's worth nine side.
I think he's lived in the desert.
He's lived on that rock. Yeah.
I don't think his started with a normal
brain. Oh really? Oh, interesting.
That's a lifetime of cognitive
impairment interests. Really.
Something for sure. So like your
whole life, you're not normal. Yeah.
Yeah. You're like, no,
no sunblock for me again.
He did that get in the usual long
school bus. Yeah. Oh really? Yeah.
Gotcha.
Good. I like him and I don't feel sorry
for him the way to everybody else. Yeah.
He makes the best of it. Good for
him, man. Care what it looks like.
Well,
I really lost my mind on this because
my producer Blue Band said he,
uh, he names all these
files. Yeah. And uh,
what really made me flip
out is that he named the,
they're usually things like just
staying alive or like, yeah.
Closer look at his
teeth. Yes. But he used,
he called this one using lung
infection as an instrument.
Yeah.
He does have a pulmonary issue.
Yep.
Salmon of lungs. Yeah. As a, as an
instrument. It's nice. I dig every,
he makes the best of everything this guy.
See that's why I like her.
You were saying there's a
chance he's a smoker though too.
That would help explain some of the skin
stuff too, right? Yeah. Oh yeah. God,
I really can you see like he's Kinda got
to expect to see like tobacco stained
fingers. Yeah, sure. Yeah,
he smokes definitely.
I mean it looks like there's
a little discoloration here.
You don't see that anymore. I
see a lot of that stuff. I bet.
Especially with Rehab, right. Cause
you're working really ages your skin.
But it's weird you guys,
people would, you know,
I practice medicine long enough to
have seen historical stuff come and go.
And this business of, there was a,
there was a women's thing for awhile,
for a long while where
a woman's identity was,
I'm the woman with the cigarette and
the Martini. Oh right. And that's,
that's what, that's who I am is by high
liberate myself and to find myself.
And when those women hit their late
seventies and I was telling them to stop
smoking,
you were thought I was telling
them to like give me your soul.
Like they'd start shattered.
Like I can't,
I'm sure you understand what you're
asking. Who I am. Yeah. It's my,
my give up your belief
in Christ. Yes. Yes.
That's who I'd be if I had quit. I loved
smoking. I mean I stopped, but you did it,
but it wasn't,
you wouldn't have a sick like a cigarette
holder and that kind of Korea crazy
bark. I don't know if it's just, you
can think of those old, those old,
those old posters, you know. Oh,
they're great. And the imagery.
It's something funny about in movies,
I still can kind of romanticize cigarettes
popping in and out in the lighting.
Yeah, the ritual of it. Yeah, you get
it. I get that. But at the same time,
it's so bizarre. Well, in life though,
when I see someone step out of it, sorry,
what are you doing? I, I become that
person that way where I go like,
I can't believe this person is doing that.
Especially with today's knowledge,
you that you live in the world now, you're
exposed to all that information. It's,
in fact, I was last night watching, I'm
dying up here. Do you watch it a second.
Okay. We'll, Goldie was up at three in
the morning and she's always slogan.
I thought, damn, that would
work. You'd keep you use it
as a stimulant. Stay awake.
I get,
if she wouldn't have that any more
smoke and drink constantly in that show.
It makes me crazy. But it's
also 17 oh yeah. All right.
Well we've come to see mother,
the mystery mystery songs.
We've come to the, uh, Oh God, the final,
this is the one we've really
been cherishing for you.
And there was not a lot of poop today.
Like my son's warned me.
That's interesting. Well, we
got to do our own discussion
of it. Uh, okay. Okay. Yeah,
that was fun. But now we're going to
see if you're part of the gang. Okay.
So here, what was that? What
did that say? See Susan,
go close your eyes. No, you can,
you won't be able to tell because it's
all in the audio, but it will please, uh,
we'll, we'll bring her in for
her take on. Okay. Um, all right.
So this guy has some advice
for just the general public.
He's has advice,
he has some thoughts on some things that
are actually medically related. Oh, good.
And maybe you can support
or if you feel so inclined,
a dispute what he suggests.
Did you pet any kind of correct. How
disorder problems? I'm here to tell you,
forget that bag or forget
about salad spaghetti,
that Dick and plants and all that stuff.
So I don't know if you believe
me or not that he like the same.
You smoked meth with a small limp.
Dick.
Did that get hardly any other way and
watch it get harder and than Lorez smoke
harder. My Dick get this. Unbelievable.
That could happen. That could happen,
right? Yeah. Okay. Well let's keep going.
You want to take a video of whatever
I have videos. Just a still of me.
I just got to get your face for
the audience that that's possible.
It says a priapism is what he's
getting. Really. So really? Yeah.
Now would you suggest to
somebody who's like, no,
that is not a treatment for extra
socks. You shouldn't smoke. No,
he should not smoke meth.
But what if they're like,
I've tried Viagra and
I'm trying to say no, no,
I have bad but it's bad.
But we were shocked to know that there
was some medicinal value to math.
I say as a side effect, it's a side effect
that you get erect. It's a priapism.
W I explained a priapism is like,
uh,
is is what my radio parties
called clinical boner. Okay.
It's like it gets extra from and can
come down and it can actually cut off its
own blood supply.
And this is a common
occurrence with no. Okay. But,
but certain medicines, certain
substances can't cause it even to the PD,
you fives, you know the Viagara isn't
that kind of stuff can cause it.
This guy finds it so important. He
uses it. He likes it. Well I'll,
I'll let him tell you.
Okay.
You won't believe how good it
feels. Good. You're straight.
He won't believe how good it builds.
Your dickhead becomes so sensitive
that you don't need lube.
You don't need spirit. You just strip that
Dick head this up and down four times.
It's this band to do it and you
shoot and norm is very thick,
hot,
white come.
Those are details I needed.
Um, there's more, oh, this
more? Yeah. No, there's no way.
Just when you think it can't get grocer,
brace yourself is definitely more, okay.
More calm than I'd ever done in my
life. And I know I'm gay. I love it.
Get blowjobs.
And I'd tell you what,
I cannot wait to affect that.
Been hot, horny home man.
I let anybody second give me a blow job.
Yeah.
So that's, yeah, it says, here we go,
good hypersexual and all that
stuff in math that happens.
And you're saying like you don't
recommend anyone to do it though.
Where Tom don't put words in
my mouth. I mean, how dare you.
Why would I suggest something you
never say always or never in medicine?
Well, here's the next piece that I
think both things are going to enjoy.
My brother didn't believe me and when
he smoked with me, he put his dick.
I can't believe how big his dick was.
He checked off for stroke
and shot the most confident.
Every shot is like he's
only 49 and he's fine.
He has no neuropathy problems at all.
He's Dick is even harder and thicker
and even more company believes me now.
So to recap, yeah, he's
sold us on the math.
Sol for erectile dysfunction is the
or other was not a believer, but he,
when they smoked together,
his brother pulled out his dick and he
couldn't believe how big his brothers
Dick was and how much it produced. And
then he jerked off in four strokes. Yeah.
And it was so much and his
brother believes him now. Yeah.
And this gentleman
is delighted and impressed
by very impressed. He also
pointed out medicinally,
I was wondering if you could weigh in
on this. He said my brother is only 49,
no neuropathy. Neuropathy
because he was having neuropathy.
So he's like,
he's got like
the neuropathy effect erections. Is
that why it's uh, with diabetes. Ah,
so maybe that's why he's
bringing it up at all. It's that,
so I'm figuring he's diabetic
and so to just summarize,
Tom Diabetic should
smoke crack and win back.
Those are the people
that really benefit from,
and you're putting your name on the line,
the doctor just stamp of approval.
In fact, if in fact they get the, the,
particularly with smoke cocaine and,
and sometimes it's bad diabetics get
horrible problems with, with these,
with the diabetics are especially prone
to just severe medical problems from
both. Oh, horrible. Horrible, horrible.
And made these gone in short order.
Is it possible that kid is
due for diabetic? He did it.
He did it. He, you know, he could the
medical community get behind. Well,
let's go get him. Let's get
him over to Harvard and, uh,
bring them to the medical school or
unlock the mystery because the, the,
the neuropathy line was giving me trouble
last time over this for this guy has
been in our lives now.
I'm so glad to hear that.
And I believe him biggest tableaus
couldn't believe it. Wait a minute,
and I'm assuming that's his source
of his erectile dysfunction. Right.
And that's why he's saying you're
blowing my mind. Wait, what's the,
the source of it is the diabetes,
the diabetes.
And that's why he's so geeked
to have a big hard dick. Yeah.
From a little limp dick to a big hard day.
Now what's with a thick heart calm.
Why is it so thick? And, and did my
wife just throw up? She was like,
yeah. Um, it doesn't, it does
increase the thickness of your,
you're dehydrated from math. Yeah. Right.
Yeah. And if you're sexually stimulated,
your prostate will begin to produce a
bit of fluid into the seminal vesicle.
So it was probably just a little
bit more than usual. Yeah.
He's stoked on it and he's just stoked
and he's got something coming. Well,
so I'm going back on my private prison
thing. It may not be priapism that he had.
It may just be his yeah.
Experience with math. Yeah.
It sounds like what Dr Drew's saying
for our listening audience. Try it out.
You know? See what happens. We're
going to have Tom try at first.
[inaudible] right. Well it sounds
like he wants to be so interesting.
Let's play it out here today.
You do anything illegal.
I don't want you to do anything illegal
and I don't want you to do anything or
don't feel comfortable doing. Of course,
I promise you, if you can, Fannie body,
you know that won't get you into trouble,
smokes and man,
and the more you smoke
up that bow hardier deep,
we'll get your dick won't get hard.
Let me try.
I didn't want to see me go from too hard.
I would do it this to clarify
and that will be tape it from,
this is small Dick, very
lamp and watching. Well,
I want to know why you guys
haven't searched the land. Got It.
Ready? I mean, no. Oh, what happened
was I'll show it to you. I mean,
I'm a little disappointed
when you personally,
we shared this and we really
celebrated this tee shirt.
There's a t shirt. No, no.
There are two t shirts
and a hat and by the way,
much to Christina's Chagrin
it for stroke gang.
A guy on Matt telling you to Jack Your
Dick for four stroke gang had the fourth
stroking motor shirt and the forest
oak and golf shirts. I would say,
I would say that this would be,
these are sort of billboards
against smoking crack.
You don't know how the male mind
works. You don't get, it was like, no,
people don't buy. We had to
reorder this one within two days.
We were restocking this one.
Now I have news for you.
I'm going to Las Vegas this weekend. I
want to proudly wear that hat. Oh, I fuck.
I wish I had brown hair. I would
definitely. Is there something else that
I'm opposed to the four stroke gang as
a piece of Merch exing out half of our
audience.
There's no woman,
normal mental faculties that
wants to wear a force. Surely.
Oh my God. She wants to wear
shirt in Las Vegas for stroke.
You're going to wear that shirt.
She's been in this room too long.
You see what happens to people get scared.
My shame diminishes. I started
participating with you guys. It really is.
Christie. I just want
to interject. Excuse me,
Christina saying this x is out half
the audience, the female audience.
I just wanted to show you.
It's the dude's getting them
to where I want to volunteer.
Exhibit a is that a woman might wear that.
She's wearing black guys who like to fuck.
Fuck good for hot black guy and you want
to fuck me at 2195 black guys that love
fuck and fuck good.
If you were hot black guy and you love
the fuck black guys love to fucking fuck
good. If you're a hot black
guy and you want to fuck me, it
doesn't matter if you're hot
black guy and you want to,
these are all listeners of
our show. Okay. Who they are.
They're submitting videos of the try
it out. Guy Who you covered last time.
Yes. That's the, they're all period.
And this guy loved the fuck
the fuck if you're a hot block.
What's weird though. Yeah.
It's not as disturbing.
One of the women are doing it right.
There's charming. It's entertaining.
But you try and tell me these chicks
won't wear the forest and they're fans.
They're up there. There were proudly,
see, but, but again, there's,
there's always a dude behind that. Yeah.
Yeah. There's always some guy going, oh,
we could do this. I want you, we'll put
a mustache. I did the great, yeah. So,
so in a way it's not their own autonomous
decision making the results in the
forest. It's a theory. I think some of
them would even get upset and be like,
Dr Dre, oh, I would like to know, please
write in. Yeah. Because, because, because,
because if that was your idea,
the young lady and you
executed on your own slow clap,
I will say too still cause
horror because that's,
we're evolving that as a
species to support. We are.
Oh really? You think so? Yeah.
I think true that our audience,
we do have women that are that down
for they get done that they would self
initiate this Tiwana no, I need
to know. I will say this in, in,
in your defense of your theory,
when I was a touring last year,
a lot of times women would
come up to me and go, uh,
my boyfriend said to tell you yes.
And we learned this eye level.
I work with coral reefs always go
because a woman would call with a prank,
something. We go, okay, where's the Dude
Uber, which up to that and it always,
not 99% one hut, no one time there was
not, there was one time there was not.
And we literally like befriended
her and said, you can't believe us.
We had a neat nicknamed her and like,
you know,
we just kept her around because it was
such a, it was, it was uh, you know,
some o z a unicorn just to further
this we restocked to try it out,
which is that guy we restocked a ball hog,
my water champ hat sold out.
So we had to recite that.
And also it guess what,
guess what sold out and you hit your star.
You're not Los Angeles shirt.
That's a bunch of those are restocked in
the store merchant method guide to walk
around with something unless vague. It's
just going to make the trip worthwhile.
It really is.
Cause I'm going to collect,
see what your listeners or viewers
to see what I got. Oh you got, yeah.
We need to know who they are, what
they're up to and I'm sorry, how to,
he's gonna be quite a weekend.
Your heart now.
Wonderful people. Very nice.
This is a, this is such a treat.
I mean I really want to make
this irregular like thing
where you come every once
in a while. Oh yeah, yeah. The Bacon it,
but she'll be on demand by your
viewers and listeners. Oh yes.
I'd come here every week if were up to me.
It's so you got it.
They have to want it. Day One. Believe me,
it takes a while to you.
Last time,
I must admit I was much more disturbed
by the end. Oh really? Yeah. Yeah.
So you need to up your game a
little bit, Tom. Well I think,
you know the interesting
thing is you say Tom,
but really what you're saying
is your mom's house listeners.
You heard it from the doctor's mouth.
He doesn't think I,
and I'd like to get into the anomalies,
the medical weird and stuff.
I think you guys would like that with
me cause I think you don't have no,
you don't understand it did. It would,
if I could bring it to life for you,
I think you would have its own little
life. Well let's put a call out there.
You guys. Medical Anomaly, medical
word stuff. Stds in a weird, weird,
weird, that's just weird behaviors. But
we're medical stuff. You'd be amazed the,
the, the array and you may not, you
know, it doesn't have to even be as sad.
So many of your videos that
start out with me. Sad. Yeah.
It could be just intriguing. I was about
to play a song that was in this folder,
but then I realized that Dj
skull vomit sent that song. Um,
that was so good.
Remember the one I played on my phone?
I'm trying to remember it.
Yeah.
I'm immediately a fan of anybody
named sculptural. I know there.
So we had to Fart. BARF. Do you ever see
that bad fart borrow? Oh, you'd love them.
They were a primate masks and
you would never see their faces.
And they are this sort of hardcore
electronic fart bar. Jesus Christ. Look,
it's your life. You're like, okay. This
is called your mom's house scat anthem.
Oh No. Produced by Fart Simpson. Um, yeah,
so a doctor drew. Thank you so much. It's
such a privilege. I love seeing you guys.
You want to say what? Are you good? Sorry.
Yeah, of course. What I said come say hi.
At least we, we there. I
was too enraptured this, uh,
your plugs. Yeah. To your plaque. Do your
plugs, come on. Oh, I get to do as plugs.
So you have to do it all.
Well of course there's Dr Com where you
can find all the podcasts. Dr Do does,
but thanks for having,
yeah. Tell us about the,
and I'm sorry that this wasn't set
up. Uh, no, it's okay. The way that,
um,
you know,
drew comes in and analyzes these
things is like a very specific thing.
But I uh, you guys have
multiple podcasts. Yes.
So the one we want you guys to
come on as this life podcast,
which you've done all that.
I loved it.
It was going to try to hook you
up with the Janice Dickinson.
Loved to have a couple other podcasts.
I have to quit working so hard.
It's really hard to pin you down and
now you're going to have a baby now.
It's a mess. It's okay. See, I know
it will happen. And what's your,
do you have a couple of your own
as well? Well, I have one that I,
I've done over the years with psychic
mediums, which, awesome. Yes. Sign.
And you were amazing actually. Tom
Hated it, but Christina was great.
It was a trip.
There were accurate about a lot of stuff
they predicted he was going to be a
movie star during, no, I
don't think, I don't remember.
You were a little closed off.
I wanted to, I wanted to Redo.
I Dunno why I, I I got to
get, he was not digging it.
I was sure I was, I was a
bit of a skeptic. Yeah. But
I liked, I liked your, uh,
the medium and she was very
nice. You know, they are, I mean,
it's funny because sometimes you get
great mediums with your guest and I think
more of the spirits were coming
for Christina. Oh, she's,
I have a better personality or they
want on that note, anything else?
So all the, uh, part of
it that are podcasts,
this life you live Hashtag you live
is our popular one with addiction,
not addiction,
but more celebrities like yourselves.
And then we also have a new
one called swell patrol,
which is more fitness oriented.
You just show off the guns for us.
There would is the host and so it drew
may not even be there like it's Mike show
and he loved that video. He
sent it to us. The, Oh wait,
did you send video at the woman
pooping? Yeah, I got that.
I got that feed. That was,
that's my catheter was Kathryn Woods
feature x y I think I just met him.
Oh yeah, he's got, he's
got some good stuff. Yeah,
but he's doing a fitness
and health podcasts,
which is very mainstream and we're really
digging it. I, I'm very excited for him.
Excellent. All right. Um,
and then doctor Judith calm.
Just go there and you can find everything.
All the shows are there and you guys
are going to go party spokes of Meth in
Vegas right here?
Yes.
Go to a titty bar. Oh Wow. You
guys. Do you guys get it? Oh yeah.
I can't wait to dr two goes wild.
All right now. Thanks for
coming you guys. My favorites.
Actually,
it's kind of funny.
I'm taking one of my psychic mediums
to Vegas this weekend. Yes. Oh,
I'm going to try to win some money. Oh,
good call. He didn't meet Rebecca fearing,
but she, she's actually
going with me. Yes. Yes.
And I'm going to ask her to tell me
what to do better. You want to come?
I'd like to give you some cash now.
He believes in it.
Do you mind if I go and I
come back on the simulator?
No. Really? Seriously. I, well,
I like hanging out with Rebecca,
but I said wouldn't it be fun to go to,
I'm going to bed on a game.
What's the game? I'm betting on
Andrew the NBA finals. So yeah,
give me some big,
these are games or game
seven is Celtics calves.
Oh. Do you have any inclination
of what you're gonna do?
Are we're going to put it all
on her? Yes. Yes. Interesting.
Let me know how that goes. I've done that
before. And Are you going to wait for,
did Oklahoma was going to wage your
real money? Hell yeah. You are? Yeah,
of course. It's called. It's
called real money. I mean,
you're going to throw a dime down on
this thing right now. I don't think so,
although, well, we don't have
to pay my mortgage this month.
So I was thinking maybe I'm just joking.
Well, if you guys want to meet
drew, there is a possibility.
If you get into meth and
crack and serious drugs,
he might treat you.
Yeah. You guys need to be
a horrible way to [inaudible] having me.
Here's drew.
Dr Drew,
do you really? It's so uncomfortable,
but it'll make you look good on camera.
I sat in a chair yesterday for a
shoot and it was a drummer's chair.
It's comfortable. It's the weirdest thing.
It's supposed to be freer, Paul. Yeah,
this is good. I like it. Even
though I slouched down in
it. Most of the shows. Yeah.
Yeah. Well thank you again for
doing this. All right. Listen,
anytime you guys my favorite
anytime, anywhere. You know,
you got some stuff coming up. We're gonna
try to come see you. Yeah, please do. So.
All right guys. Thanks for
listening. See you next week.
Bye Bye.
Did you get up after that?
But that sketch,
how's it really good? My ancestors, Tommy,
I'm a whore
scanning.
I don't need to my guy and
it's not really that healthy orange juice.
What do you like
best about listening to somebody
scam? I mean, it's just like,
I just feel it in meetings.